the death toll continues to rise in
pakistan from devastating floods
authorities report at least 50 deaths in
the deluge hit sindh province in recent
days more than 1200 people have died in
the past weeks
satellite imagery shows the scale of the
flooding which has affected about a
third of the country there are now
concerns the country's crop of wheat
could be wiped out affecting food supply
officials say the record monsoon rains
and melting glaciers are being caused by
climate change
pakistan has appealed for more
international aid and the country's
largest charity the eti foundation has
urged the government to reverse a ban on
many international ngos to allow them to
help
the evidence of formal lives lies
scattered throughout this vast rural
area now underwater
these used to be people's homes but now
are largely submerged or destroyed
those displaced by the floods are
flocking to this camp in the sindh
province searching for food medicine and
a place to stay
many of them don't have to think too
much about their priorities
the whole town is underwater
nothing could be saved
there's no food available no rice no
vegetables there's nothing here
all that the people worry about is food
many say they don't even care about
getting tents
only food
the camp has an improvised hospital
which is accepting people without charge
volunteer doctors try to do what they
can to relieve the suffering of the sick
we provide cannula and drip as most
patients who come here suffer from
diarrhea malaria high grade fever and
skin problems
at our outpatient department five to six
doctors treat 700 to 800 patients every
day
these makeshift tents are filling up
quickly with most of the locals having
nowhere else to go
setting up for an even more uncertain
life they briefly sum up what happened
to them in the last few weeks
there was a hundred percent loss for our
crops
nothing could be saved as far as the
crops are concerned
rice
cotton vegetables and fruits
all have been destroyed
as the aid groups step up their efforts
they as well as pakistan's government
are appealing to the world for more help
for the devastated communities
but for now all that these desperate
people can do is to stick to such camps
on the few remaining patches of dry land
we'll go to islamabad now and speak to
adil sharaz the country director at the
aid organization care international in
pakistan uh thank you for joining us
you just returned from the southwestern
province of balochistan which has been
hit by the worst of the flooding what
was the situation like there
i would say the situation is extremely
challenging because uh a large
population is affected from this flood
uh during our recent uh visit to the
different parts of pakistan including
balochistan and sin we have seen
villages are washed away and there is a
large destruction which has happened out
of this flooding uh in terms of uh crops
which are destroyed
uh the bridges which are washed away
roads are washed away and also people
have lost shelter livestock and
livelihood on which they were dependent
so
there are affected area which has been
hard hit from this flooding and there's
a large population who have lost all the
basic things which they need to live a
healthy life
and the authorities are reporting 33
million people affected 90 percent of
them haven't received any assistance yet
what's most needed in terms of aid and
how does it get to people
the area in terms of geographical
coverage is quite big like we are
talking about 33 million people who are
affected at least 72 districts are
affected in this emergency so this is
really a large coverage we are talking
about uh
more and more aid organization and
government is reaching out to these
affected areas and providing assistance
but we all need to understand we are
talking about a large population at this
stage
the most important needs are food
uh the shelter which is required
at the same time sanitation facilities
are either very limited or they don't
exist
in terms of like you know gender in
emergency organization like care is
working a lot on that we do see
emergency in terms of what are the
gender needs in that area and we do feel
a lot of like support which is required
for the female population in the
affected area including making sure that
they get the ministerial hygiene kit
they need
sanitation facilities which are near to
where they are living so that it can
minimize the risk of security
we also need to ensure that there is
clean drinking water available in this
area we are hearing and also witnessing
more and more water bond diseases which
are coming including
diarrhea malaria skin diseases and
others
and all of that require an immediate
support and need aid workers like us and
also other organization are reaching out
to these affected population
but at the same time logistically this
operation is challenging because of
still water in certain area which is
making uh supplies and aid workers to
reach out to these population in in a
more time as compared to before well sir
it sounds like an incredibly challenging
and tragic situation given that um
why isn't the government allowing some
of these banned foreign ngos from
working again in the country
there are a large number of
international organization already in
country and the government i would say
have been very positive about giving
them permission to work in these
affected areas
there is a mechanism available uh to
allow apply and allow for the new
organization to come in country and i
think as as long as they can complete
the requirement there will be more and
more organization can come into the
country but organization like us we have
seen with the positive response from the
government side in terms of providing
access in terms of providing permission
to work in these affected population
areas
so i can say fairly that organizations
are getting support which are in country
uh the new organization organization who
are working before in country uh they
need to just use the right channel to
apply for permission to work in country
and i'm sure there will be facilitation
from the government side okay message
received adil sharaz thanks so much
thank you so much
you